THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD. ZERO CHIANG.
DODD.
THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TITLE.
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MONNING.
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MARIA [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WHY CASKEY?
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
BEGIN ASK EVERYONE TO PLEASE
STAND.
MEMBERS AS WE KNOW ON EASTER
SUNDAY ONE OF THE HOLIEST DAYS
FOR CHRISTIANS.
AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
AND SEVERAL HUNDREDS MORE WERE
INJURED.
NEAR SIMULTANEOUS ATTACKS AT
CHURCHES AND HOTELS IN TRY LANKA.
THE ATTACKS OCCURRED IN HOTEL
RESTAURANTS WERE FAMILIES WERE
ENJOYING EASTER BRUNCH.
AND HOUSES OF WORSHIP WHICH ARE
MEANT TO BE SANCTUARIES OF PEACE
FAITH AND HARMONY.
DURING THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME
IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR SRI
LANKAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS WE
WOULD NOW LIKE TO OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE. FOR THE
HUNDREDS OF VICTIMS FROM
YESTERDAY'S TRAGEDY.
AS WELL AS THEIR FAMILIES AND
LOVED ONES THAT ARE NOW IN DEEP
MOURNING ACROSS TRY LOG BLANKA.
AND IN THE WORLD BUT AS OBSERVE
A MOMENT OF SILENCE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS BEYOND THE
RAW RAIL YOU'RE ALL STANDING
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE'LL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN.
VERY REVEREND FATHER BY YOUR
SHOES ON IAN PASTOR OF SAINT
GREGORY THE ILLUMINATOR ARMENIAN
APOSTLE CHURCH.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WE WILL HAVE THE
COMMITMENT SANTA CLARA ANY
CHAPTER COLOR GUARD POSTS THE
COLORS I WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR WILK.
ETERNAL AND ALL MIGHTY LORDS OR
GODS.
WE THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THIS
BEAUTIFUL DAY.
WITH UPRIGHTS PERIOD.
AND THROUGH WORDS. TO THANK YOU
FOR EVERYTHING YOU HAVE GIVEN US
[inaudible]
DEAR FATHER.
WE ARE GATHERED HERE TO REMEMBER
AND TO COMMEMORATE.
THE HUNDRED AND FOURTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
AND TO PREPARE FOR THE SOULS OF
YOUR CREATURES AND SAINTS.
OUR ONE MILLION AND HEALTH.
COMPATRIOTS WHO PERISHED DURING
THESE GENOCIDE.
OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS AT THE
STATE SENATE'S.
JOIN US TODAY IN REMEMBERING
THIS TRAGIC EVENT.
AS CITIZENS OF THIS BEAUTIFUL
COUNTRY.
AND AS MEMBERS OF THESE ADVANCED
SOCIETY.
BRING YOU OUR VOWS TO ALWAYS
RAISE AWARENESS AND TO KEEP OUR
PROMISE.
BY REMEMBERING.
CAM REMINDING EVERYONE ABOUT THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
YET TO BE RECOGNIZED BY THE
PERPETRATOR.
PREPARE WE PRAY FOR SO MUCH
DESIRED PEACE.
BOAT WITHIN OURSELVES AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
GIVE US YOUR DIVINE PIECE WHICH
IS BEYOND OUR CONTROL
COMPREHENSION.
AND SPREAD YOUR LOVE EVERYWHERE
SO WE CAN ALL CO EXIST IN
HARMONY.
LORD OUR FATHER.
WE ASK YOUR BLESSINGS AND WE USE
THEM TO DESCEND UPON OUR SOUL.
ESPECIALLY BONO LEADERS. TO
DISPEL OLD WEAKER TOTES AND DIPS
FROM OUR MINUTES IN FROM
EVERYWHERE.
SO THAT WE CAN PREVENT FUTURE
GENOCIDES AND INJUSTICE AGAINST
HUMANITY.
WOULD BE SEAT YOU.
CAN ASK FROM YOU ALL BENEVOLENT
CAUGHT.
FIFTH GUARD ARE VERY PRECIOUS
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY.
SO WE CAN ALWAYS DEFEND.
AND PRESERVE JUSTICE FOR OLD
[inaudible]
I'M IN.
COLOR GUARD PLEASE POST THE
COLORS
. FOR YOUR HEART REPEAT
AFTER ME [inaudible] FIVE YEAH.
AND THIS IS A LITTLE
[inaudible]
THIS CALL.
COLOR GUARD PLEASE RETIRED THE
COLORS
.
THANK YOU TO OUR COLOR GUARD
THAT WAS A TREAT FOR US TODAY.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH S. R.
THIRTY ONE WHICH IS ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR BOARD JONES.
SENATOR BORDERS OF THE PRO TEM
STATUS MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR BOARD JUST RELATIVE TO
THE COMMEMORATION OF THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
THROUGH.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE SENATOR
BOARD YES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
IN COLLEAGUES.
BEAR WITH ME PLEASE.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION.
THIRTY ONE WHICH COMMEMORATES
THE ANNIVERSARY ONE OF THE MOST
ATROCIOUS HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS IN HISTORY.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
BEGINNING ON APRIL.
TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN FIFTEEN THE
ARMENIAN PEOPLE A MINOR MINOR
ASIA WERE SUBJECTED TO A
SYSTEMATIC.
IN PREMEDITATED GENOCIDE.
AT THE HAND OF THE HANDS OF THE
YOUNG TURKS GOVERNMENT OF THE%
OTTOMAN EMPIRE.
AND CONTINUED AT THE HANDS OF
THE CLOCK COME ALL THIS MOVEMENT
OF TURKEY UNTIL.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE WERE BY
OVER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ARMENIAN MEN.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE
SLAUGHTERED OR MARCH TO THEIR
DEATHS IN EFFORT TO ANNIHILATE
THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE.
AS PART OF AMERICAN FOREIGN
POLICY UNDER PRESIDENT WOODROW
WILSON.
THE NEAREST RELIEF ORGANIZATION
WAS FOUNDED IN AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE
AND RESCUE WE ARMENIANS GREEKS
ASSYRIANS.
IN OTHER CHRISTIAN MINORITIES
FROM ANNIHILATION IN MINOR ASIA.
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING PROOF
OF GENOCIDAL INTENT THE REPUBLIC
OF TURKEY ADAMANTLY DENIED THE
OCCURRENCE OF THE CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY COMMITTED BY THE AUTUMN
IN AND YOUNG TURK RULERS.
AND CONTINUES TO DO SO OVER A
FULL CENTURY SINCE THE CRIMES
OCCURRED.
CALIFORNIA AS WE ALL KNOW IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST ARMENIAN
AMERICAN POPULATION UNITED
STATES AND ARMENIANS LIVING
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN REACHED OUR
STATE THROUGH THEIR LEADERSHIP.
AND CONTRIBUTIONS IN BUSINESS
AGRICULTURE ACADEMIA GOVERNMENT
AND THE ARTS.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO EXPERIENCE FIRSTHAND THE
HORRORS OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
IN ITS ONGOING DENIAL.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
REMAIN RESULT IN THEIR SPIRIT
CONTINUES TO THRIVE MORE THAN A
CENTURY AFTER THEIR NEAR
ANNIHILATION.
ON A VERY PERSONAL LEVEL.
THE STORY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE TRULY HITS HOME.
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ARMENIANS
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION GREEKS
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ASSYRIANS WERE SLAUGHTERED IN
THE FIRST GENOCIDE.
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
IN THE SUMMER OF NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO A TEN YEAR OLD GIRL NAMED
KAI AND ALONG WITH HER FAMILY.
FLIGHT FROM THE COUNTRYSIDE OF
MUNTASIR TO THE PORT CITY OF
ZMIR NOW. FOR WEEKS SHE AN
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
OTHER REFUGEES HUDDLED IN
DESPERATE CIRCUMSTANCES.
TRYING TO ESCAPE THE HORRORS
COMING FOR THEM BY THE TURKISH
ARMY.
MEANWHILE IN THE PORT BRITISH
FRENCH AND AMERICAN BOATS WERE
ANCHORED OUT OF REACH IN THE
HARBOR.
REFUSING TO TAKE REFUGEES
WITHOUT ORDERS IN UNTIL A FIRE
BROKE OUT.
THAT WOULD IN GOAL FOR THE CITY
CAN BURN THE REFUGEES ALIVE AT
THE HARBOR.
THIS TICKET.
THIS TEN YEAR OLD GIRL WAS.
AND MY WIFE'S GRANDMOTHER.
AS EXTRAORDINARY FORTUNE WOULD
HAVE IT A SMALL BIT BAPTISMAL
GIFT OF A HAT ADORNED WITH THE
AMERICAN FLAG ON IT.
WAS WRAPPED AROUND HER ARM.
A BEING ABLE TO SPEAK SOME
ENGLISH.
THEY MISTOOK THE HAD A SOME SORT
OF OFFICIAL BAD.
AND ALLOWED HER IN THE WOMEN OF
THE FAMILY TO BOARD SHIP A SHIP
TO GREECE.
MANY OTHERS WERE NOT SO LUCKY
AGAIN WOULD PERISH AT THE HARBOR.
BY EITHER THE FIRE FOR THE TURKS.
WITHOUT PAPERS WITHOUT MONEY AND
WITHOUT RESOURCES.
THEY MADE GREASE THEIR HOME
BEFORE COMING TO AMERICA IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
THIS STORY OF TRAGEDY IN
SURVIVAL IS SHARED THROUGHOUT
THE ARMENIAN GREEK AN ASSYRIAN
COMMUNITIES.
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
MY WIFE ANA AND I TRAVEL BACK TO
SMYRNA. TO RETRACE HER STEPS AND
CONNECTS WITH HER FAMILY'S
DARKEST CHAPTER.
I CANNOT BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW.
AND DISQUIETING.
IT WAS TO BE AT THE VERY HARPER.
WHEN ON A COLD HER NINETY FOUR
YEAR OLD GRANDMOTHER?
IN DEFIANTLY SPOKE IN ARMENIAN.
IN THE FRONT OF THE LAST GREEK
DIPLOMATIC BUILDING STILL
STANDING FROM THAT ERA.
AT THE VERY HARBOR WHERE SHE
FLED FOR SURVIVAL.
LOOKING BACK AT THE TRIP I
CANNOT HELP BUT RECALL THE WORDS
OF FRESNO WRITER WILLIAM SAROYAN.
WHO WROTE?
I SHOULD LIKE TO SEE ANY POWER
OF THE WORLD DESTROY THIS RACE.
THEN SEE IF THEY WILL NOT LAUGH.
SING AND PRAY AGAIN. FOR WHEN
TWO OF THEM MEET ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
SEE IF THEY WILL NOT CREATE.
A NEW ARMENIA.
THE FACT THAT THEY WERE THERE
SPEAKING TO CHI INTO.
THAT WE WERE THERE SPEAKING THAT
HIGH IN IT PROVES.
THE TURKS INDEED FAILED.
THE ARMENIANS WILL NOT BE
STRICKEN FROM THIS EARTH
[inaudible]
AB.
AS OUR THIRTY ONE WILL DESIGNATE
APRIL AS THE MONTH OF
COMMEMORATION OF THE HUNDRED
FOURTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
AND URGED THE PRESIDENT AND
CONGRESS TO HAVE HE COURAGE TO
FALLING DECLARE WHAT OCCURRED
FROM NINETEEN FIFTEEN TO
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE AS WHAT IT
WAS.
GENOCIDE.
WE HOPE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL RECOGNIZE THAT TURKEY IS
NEITHER A LOYAL FRIEND NOR A
TRUE NATO ALLY.
AND JUSTICE SHOULD NOT BE
SUBORDINATED TO POLITICAL
CONVENIENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY COLLEAGUES
REQUEST YOUR FIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PORCHES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE
ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AS OUR THIRTY ONE
I'M SO PROUD TO REPRESENT THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO.
WHICH I BELIEVE IS THE SECOND
LARGEST CITY TO WHO.
HAS A COMMUNITY OF ARMENIANS
GREAT ARMENIANS I MAY ADD WHO
HAVE SERVED OUR COUNTRY IN THE
MILITARY ALL BRANCHES.
SURE BEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHO SERVED ALL WALKS OF LIFE?
AND THEY ARE AMERICANS.
THEY'VE COME TO THIS COUNTRY
WITH NOTHING WE'VE JUST HEARD
THEY COME TO THIS COUNTRY WITH
THE BURDEN.
OF PROOF THE BURDEN OF PROOF THE
GENOCIDE HAS HAPPENED.
WELL I THINK HISTORY WILL SHOW
THE PROOF IS HERE.
IT IS THERE IN THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO IN THE IN THE LARGEST
MONUMENT IN THE UNITED STATES.
TO SHOW THAT THERE WAS A
GENOCIDE IT IS THERE IS ENORMOUS.
AND WHEN DAYS LIKE THIS LIKE
TOMORROW WEDNESDAY THIS WEEK.
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITIES FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE F CALIFORNIA
WILL CONVERGE TO MONTEBELLO. TO
PRAY TOGETHER TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GENOCIDE.
THAT IT DID HAPPEN.
THAT WE MUST NEVER FORGET.
I ALSO WILL SHARE WITH YOU WHEN
I WAS IN THE MUD ABOUT POLICE
DEPARTMENT IT WOULD PART OF MY
DUTY MY HONOR. TO GUARD THE
MONUMENT. TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE ABUSED IN ANY WAY BY
ANYONE OVER THE NEXT -- WEEK OR
TWO BEFORE THE PREPARATION AND
WHEN I BECAME LATER IS IS THE
MAYOR OF PICO RIVERA THE
ADJOINING. TO MEET SO MANY
ARMENIANS WHO HAVE GONE TO THE
SCHOOL -- THERE AND PURE AND
PICO RIVERA TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THAT THEY'VE GRADUATED FROM PICO
RIVERA THEY'VE GRADUATED TO GO
ON IN THEIR LIVES AND AND TO
PARTICIPATE WAS AMAZING.
BUT WHAT IS MORE AMAZING THAN
ANYTHING ELSE IS THAT WE HAVE
SURVIVORS WHO ARE STILL WALKING
THIS EARTH TO BE ABLE TO TALK
AND DONE AND STERN AND SACRIFICE
SO MUCH AS WE JUST HEARD.
SO I'M SO PROUD TO SAY THAT I
STAND BEFORE YOU.
AS AN AMERICAN MEXICAN AMERICAN
WHO HAS.
GOTTEN SO MANY TIMES IN SO MANY
STORIES WITH ARMENIA AMERICANS
ABOUT THEIR SUFFERING AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
SO I HOPE THAT WE NEVER FORGET
AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU WHEN
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO VISIT
MONTEBELLO.
COME BY THAT MONUMENTS AND AND
YOU CAN.
PAY TRIBUTE TO THOSE WHO
SUFFERED A GIVEN SO MUCH SO I
AYE AYES ALSO I OF URGENT AYE
VOTE ON ESTARá THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
SENATOR RUSSELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I ALSO
STAND HERE TODAY AS THE NEWLY
ELECTED SENATOR FROM LITTLE
ARMENIA IN LOS ANGELES IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY.
THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY FIRST
SETTLED IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA
WHERE MY FAMILY ALSO LIVED FOR
DECADES.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS THAT PLAGUE OUR WORLD.
DIVERSE PEOPLE HAVE STRUGGLE TO
SURVIVE IN A WORLD.
THAT SOMETIMES HAS BEEN FILLED
WITH FEAR AND HATRED WITHOUT A
UNIVERSAL.
RESPECT FOR HUMAN RIGHTS THE
WORLD COULD NOT A CHEAP PLEASE
PIECE AND I MAIN UNIVERSAL NOT
SOMETIMES NOT IN SOME COUNTRIES
NOT SOME PLACES BUT UNIVERSAL.
ALL OF US HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO UP UP UP HOLD THAT UNIVERSAL
VALUE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD
ALWAYS STAND ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OF JUSTICE WE ARE HOME TO THOSE
WHO WERE TORN FROM THEIR
HOMELANDS.
AND THE ARMENIAN STORY IS PART
OF THE GREATER CALIFORNIA I AM
SO PROUD TO BE THE NEWLY ELECTED.
US SENATOR REPRESENT EIGHT
LITTLE ARMENIA OUR SYMPATHY GOES
TO ALL THE SURVIVORS OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
THEIR CHILDREN THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN ESPECIALLY TO THE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION PEOPLE OF
ARMENIAN DESCENT WHO ARE IN OUR
STATE.
TODAY WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
OF THE DESCENDANTS OF THE
GENOCIDE VICTIMS WHO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
ADVANCEMENT.
I WANT TO WELCOME OUR GUESTS
FROM LOS ANGELES WHO ARE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS TO TO THE SENATE
CHAMBERS AND LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE WILL NOT LET.
THIS PART OF HISTORY VANISH WE
WILL NOT LET YOUR DEMAND FOR
JUSTICE GO ON ANSWERED THANK YOU
OR CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO SENATOR
ALAN.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE LETTERS OF JEWISH
CAUCUS I WANT TO STAND IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF US ARE.
THIRTY ONE HI THE JEWISH CAUCUS
UNIT GOING TO QUICKLY RECOGNIZES
THE BRUTAL MURDER OF AN
ESTIMATED ONE POINT.
FIVE MILLION ARMENIANS BETWEEN
NINETEEN FIFTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE HAS THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
AND WE HONOR THOSE ARMENIANS
WHOSE LIVES.
WERE SYSTEMATICALLY TAKEN FROM
THEM AND STAND WITH THEIR
SURVIVORS.
MANY OF WHOM EMIGRATED IN THE
AFTERMATH TO THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND SOUGHT TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES NOW WITH THE COMMEMORATION
OF THE WHOLE CLASS SCHEDULED ON
THE SAME SENATE FLOOR FOR NEXT
WEEK WE'RE STARKLY REMINDED.
OF HOW ONE UNTHINKABLE ATROCITY
CAN BE USED TO JUSTIFY
COMMITTING A NUMBER ANOTHER.
REMINDED HOW IN NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE ADOLF HITLER JUSTIFIED HIS
INVASION OF POLAND AND HIS
EXTERMINATION OF THE JEWS BY
EXCLAIMING.
WHO AFTER ALL SPEAKS TODAY OF
THE AND I LISTEN OF THE
ARMENIANS?
HEATHER WAS EMBOLDENED BY THE
FAILURE OF THE WORLD'S
SUPERPOWERS TO RECOGNIZE THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
BELIEVING HUMANITY MIGHT STAND
SILENT AGAIN.
AND FAILED TO CONDEMN HIS
MISSION TO DESTROY THE JEWISH
PEOPLE.
AND AFTER ONE OF THE DARKEST
CHAPTERS IN HUMAN HISTORY.
THANK GOD HITLER WAS EVENTUALLY
FINALLY PROVEN WRONG.
DECADES AFTER HIS NAY **** ARMY
SURRENDERED THE TUITION ARMENIAN
PEOPLE NOT ONLY INJURE BUT IN
CALIFORNIA HERE THEY THRIVE.
IN RETURNING THE CULTURAL FABRIC
OF OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
REMINDING OF US ALL TO LEARN
FROM AND CONDEMN THE ATROCITIES
OF HISTORY.
ON BEHALF OF OUR JEWISH CAUCUS
AYE AYE SAID THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE HAS WHICH IS TO SAY OF
THE HOLOCAUST.
NEVER AGAIN.
I URGE YOUR FULL SUPPORT OF US
ARE.
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT BE
BRIEF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
THOUGH TO TO VISIT THE REPUBLIC
OF ARMENIA -- LAST FALL
[inaudible]
AND IN ADDITION TO REMEMBERING.
WHAT HISTORY IS?
I WANTED TO PRESENT TO YOU ALL
TODAY WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS.
WHICH IS A THRIVING DEMOCRACY.
THAT STOOD ON ITS OWN TWO FEET.
IN THE FACE OF TREMENDOUS
DISASTER AND I CAN ONLY COMPARE
IT TO A NATION LIKE ISRAEL.
WHICH IS A SMALL BUT MIGHTY
REPUBLIC.
WHERE WOMEN AND MINORITIES ARE
ELEVATED?
AND WHERE -- THE THE
TOTALITARIAN SORT OF VESTIGES OF
THAT REGION OR SHIRKED OFF IN
FACT THEY LET THEIR OWN VELVET
REVOLUTION LAST YEAR.
WHERE THEY DECLARED THEIR OWN
NATIONS?
SELF DETERMINATION.
AND THEIR RESILIENCE OF THOSE
PEOPLE -- AND THE DIASPORA THAT
LIVE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUGHT TO BE
RECOGNIZED TODAY WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU CENTER STERN
CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SR -- THIRTY ONE DESIGNATED
MONTH OF APRIL THE COMMEMORATION
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND I
WAS STRUCK BY MY COLLEAGUE --
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT HIS -- WIFE'S
FAMILY STORY.
AND HOW YOU KNOW REPRESENTING A
LARGE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN IN
MY DISTRICT HOW.
PRIVILEGED I AM TO KNOW AND
LEARN AND HERE PEOPLE WHO --
THRIVE SO STRONGLY TODAY BUT GET
CHOKED UP.
APPROPRIATELY AS THEY TALK ABOUT
THEIR ANCESTORS ITSELF.
I FOUND -- THE PRESENTATION
EXTREMELY MOVING -- AND
APPRECIATE HIS HIS -- OFFERING
SR THIRTY ONE HUNDRED FOUR YEARS
AGO AS BEEN SAID ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS.
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS AND
THERE WAS A PROBABLY MENTION
ASSYRIANS GREEKS AND OTHER
CHRISTIANS.
WERE PERSECUTED AND KILLED AT
THE HANDS OF THE OTTOMAN TURKS
ON A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE A
HISTORIAN RUBINO PERUVIAN.
WROTE ABOUT -- ONE MAN JOHN
MINASSIAN.
WHO IS A GENOCIDE?
SURVIVOR WHO'S BEEN MORE.
DESCRIBE THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAD TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON HIS
LIFE -- WHEN THE OTTOMAN TURKS
BEGAN ROUNDING UP AND
IMPRISONING MEN MINASSIAN RECALL
THE YOUNG ARMENIAN -- GRADUATE
STUDENTS SAYING TO HIM.
THAT IS THE PLAN OF THE TURKS TO
PUT AN END TO ALL OF US.
BUT YOU MAY SURVIVE.
AND YOU WILL DO IT.
AND IT WILL BE YOUR OBLIGATION
TO TELL THE WORLD.
HOW IT HAPPENED AND WHY?
YOU ARE THE WITNESS TO OUR
TRAGEDY.
AND IT IS YOUR DUTY TO TELL AT
ALL AND WHAT STRUCK ME.
IN READING ABOUT -- TO JOHN IS
THE SENSE OF OBLIGATION OF THIS
PROUD PEOPLE THAT WAS.
TRYING TO BE EXT BEING
EXTERMINATED BUT STILL HAD THE
SENSE OF HISTORY AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO TELL THE WORLD.
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON AND SO
THE SURVIVORS STRUGGLED WITH
THAT TRAUMA.
THEY SHARED WITH THE WORLD THE
INHUMANE CRIMES THEY WITNESSED
AN INDOOR WORD.
AND WE OWE THEM A GREAT GREAT
DEBT OF GRATITUDE WERE IT NOT
FOR THIS RESILIENCE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE NATIONS AROUND THE GLOBE.
AND IN THE UNITED STATES FORTY
NINE STATES.
HAVE RECOGNIZE.
THE GENOCIDE [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
WASHINGTON HAS NOT. TO NAY NOW
MORE THAN EVER ARMENIAN YOUTH
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN OF THE
SURVIVORS HAVE BECOME THE
LEADERS IN ADVOCATING FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
PROPER SERVING THEIR HISTORY AND
THEIR CULTURE MANY VOLUNTEERS
IMMERSING THEMSELVES IN
ARMENIA'S DAILY LIFE AND
IMPLEMENTING INNOVATIVE IDEAS.
THAT WILL FURTHER DEVELOPMENT OF
THEIR HOMELAND.
THROUGH THEIR INVOLVEMENT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE SHOW THE WORLD.
THAT THEIR POWER AND THEIR DRIVE
IS UNBREAKABLE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE ASKED ME IN A
WHY IS -- ITALIAN AMERICAN I'M
SO PASSIONATE ABOUT.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WELL AS I
SAID I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN THE
DIASPORA I BELIEVE ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
BUT I GO BACK TO MY TIME AS A
TEN YEAR OLD.
HEARING MY MOM.
AN ITALIAN WIDOW IN NEW JERSEY
TALK ABOUT THE GENOCIDE AND I
ALWAYS ATTRIBUTE THAT. TO
WOODROW WILSON'S PRESENCE IN
CALIFORNIA IN NEW JERSEY HISTORY
AND TALKING ABOUT THE NEAR REESE
RELIEF AND SO I WAS A YOUNG BOY.
MY MOM TAUGHT OUR FAMILY ABOUT
THE HORRORS OF THE GENOCIDE IN
THE ARMENIAN OR FRIENDS THAT
WERE LEFT IN ITS WAKE AND SO.
I RESPECT HER FOR HAVING THAT
THE FORESIGHT TO TO SHARE THAT
STORY WITH HER FAMILY.
WE'VE SEEN A RISE IN HATRED AND
PREJUDICE AGAINST ALL
COMMUNITIES AROUND THEN OUR
NATION SO IT'S MORE IMPORTANT IN
EVER THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO
LEAD BY EXAMPLE.
AND REAFFIRM OUR COMMITMENT TO
CONDEMN IN JUSTICE AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ABUSES AND OUR UNWAVERING
GENOCIDE RECOGNITION.
AND IN CONCLUSION IT'S IMPORTANT
JUST TO REMEMBER HAD AS MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID WHAT
TOUCHES ONE OF US.
A TOUCHES ALL OF US AND SO IN
HONOR OF THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS WHO'VE LOST
THEIR LIVES IN THE PROUD
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SR.
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTANTINO CENTER NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LATE IN GERMAN
THE SENATE I REALIZE IS A NATIVE
OF FRESNO AND YOU CAN'T BE FROM
FRESNO WITHOUT HAVING AN AWFUL
LOT OF ARMENIAN FRANCE.
THOSE THAT I GREW UP WITH AND
FRESNO AND SANGER.
WHERE THE FIRST OR SECOND
GENERATION?
OF THOSE WHO STILL PERSONALLY.
EXPERIENCE.
INPUT FROM THAT TRAGEDY.
BUT THEY LIKE MANY OTHER
ETHNICITIES.
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
[inaudible]
OPPRESSED DIMINISH.
AND SEEKING FREEDOM.
AND SEEKING OPPORTUNITY.
IN SEEKING TO BE CONTRIBUTORS.
TO THIS GREAT NATION.
AS THEY HAVE OVER THE DECADES.
MANY HAVE SERVED IN POSITIONS OF
AUTHORITY.
INCLUDING ONE OF OUR FORMER
COLLEAGUES.
FROM SANGER.
CHECK THE SHOULD GET.
NOW RETIRED TO THE JUDGE AND
FRESNO.
AND HE SPOKE. FOR THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS.
ANOTHER THING INSTRUCTIVE TO ME
IN THE YEARS THAT I'VE SERVED
HERE FOR MANY SUCCESSIVE YEARS
[inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENTING.
THE OPPRESSORS.
IN THAT GENOCIDE.
WOULD COME HERE.
AT COME HERE.
WITH THE ONLY ARGUMENT DENYING.
THAT THIS EVER HAPPENED
[inaudible]
NOW.
FOLKS LIKE ME AND MANY OF YOU
WHO AND MANY OF YOU SEEN MORE
THAN I AND HEARD MORE STORIES
AND I HAVE.
WE KNEW THAT THAT WAS AN UNTRUTH.
AND WE DID NOT ACCEPT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
RESISTANCE THAT THEY FACED.
OVER THE YEARS.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
HAVE DISPOSED THEM.
THE EVEN QUIT TRYING TO TELL.
THE STORY OF THE NILE.
RATHER THIS SHOULD BE THE STORY
[inaudible]
A REMINDER.
END OF RENEWAL.
THE ARMENIAN GENERATIONS.
LIVING YET NOW [inaudible]
IN ARMENIA [inaudible]
AND THOSE [inaudible]
IN AMERICA.
OF THE TESTIMONY.
HIGHER DENY VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
BORDERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO GO
THROUGH WITH THOSE COMMENTS --
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU HEAR THESE
STORIES DIRECTLY -- IN YOU FEEL
THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON THE
FAMILY.
IT BECAUSE PART OF WHO YOU ARE --
THEY ONCE IT IS PART OF WHO YOU
ARE.
YOU A BRACE IT AS YOUR OWN.
AND IF FOREVER.
CHANGE YOUR OUTLOOK.
SO.
I AM VERY THANKFUL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES -- HAS EXPRESSED SUCH
WORDS OF SUPPORT.
AND I CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE -- IN
I DON'T THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORCHERS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL.
HI PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI OR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
BY MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG I AM A PILOT CASKEY
[inaudible]
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
SENATOR PORTANTINO AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT OF THAT'S OUR THIRTY ONE
ON YOUR DESKS.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ARMENIAN CAUCUS WHICH HAS
DONATED THESE BOOKS ON YOUR DESK
I EXPECT YOU ALL TO READ IT BY
NEXT YEAR'S APRIL.
SO THAT YOUR HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENT
I'M SURE THE ACADEMICS AMONG --
TO YOU READ LAST YEAR'S BOOK TO
GET IN A MS MITCHELL GETS A NAY.
BUT OBVIOUSLY PART OF TODAY IS
NOT JUST DOING THE RESOLUTION
BUT SHARING A PIECE OF HISTORY.
AND SO WE WANTED TO SHARE THIS
BOOK WITH YOU AS WELL SO I JUST
WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE CAUCUS
FOR THAT SELECTION WE ARE JOINED
BY.
OF SLEW OF HONORED GAS AND
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE VERY REVEREND FATHER BARU --
XIN AS IN -- FROM ST GREGORY THE
ILLUMINATOR ARMENIAN APOSTOLIC
CHURCH AND THE WHOLE MINUTEMEN
CYNICALLY DONNIE CHAPTER SCOUTS
FOR GRACING US TODAY WE ARE ALSO
JOINED BY -- AMBASSADOR ARMAND
BY FORTY ON WHO IS -- AMBASSADOR
BY FORTY AND HAS IN A PRESS OF
RECORD OF SERVICE IN THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY HE SERVED AS
ARMENIANS FIRST COUNCIL GENERAL
IN LOS ANGELES.
AND RECENTLY WAS REAPPOINTED
BACK TO HIS ORIGINAL POST AND
DURING HIS CAREER HE'S TWICE
SERVED AS ARMENIAN DEPUTY
FOREIGN MINISTER -- AND HE WAS
THE FIRST -- AMBASSADOR THE
INDIA NEPAL SRI LANKA AND
INDONESIA ON BEHALF OF THE
ARMENIAN REPUBLIC SO WE'RE
HONORED TO HAVE HIM HERE WITH US
TODAY.
WE ALSO HAVE GLENDALE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS OUT A SAID NINE
YEN.
AND BURBANK SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
ARMAND AGA KHAN IN WITH US HERE
AS WELL -- WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE WESTERN
DIOCESE OF THE ARMENIAN CHURCH
IN SAINT JAMES ARMENIAN
APOSTOLIC CHURCH.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA AND
THEY'RE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COUNCIL WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE ARMENIAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF AMERICA
WESTERN REGION.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
ARMENIAN YOUTH FEDERATION WE
HAVE -- THE OP PACKING FAMILY
AND ALLEN NASA TARIAN FORMER
WESTERN REGION EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ANC.
PROUD RESIDENTS OF THE TWENTY
FIFTH SENATE DISTRICT SO WE
COULD WELCOME THIS WONDERFUL
GROUP OF PEOPLE TO THE SENATE.
FOR I'D APPRECIATE IT.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE AND HOPEFULLY I DIDN'T
LEAVE ANYONE OUT
MEMBERS WE ARE
STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR.
SENATOR STERN WHEN YOU'RE READY
CENTER STERN AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
ALL OUR DISTINGUISHED GUESTS AS
THEY TRICKLE OUT -- I DO WANT TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE -- MISKITO
AWARENESS WEEK IT MAY SOUND LIKE
A SMALL THING IN EFFECT MISCUES
ARE SMALL THING BUT THEY'RE ALSO
A BIG THING.
AS TAKING CALIFORNIA'S LIVES AS
WE SPEAK.
AFTER SIGNIFICANT RAINFALL WE
RECEIVE THIS WINTER MISCUE
EXPERTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
STRESSED THE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO DUMP IN DRAIN
ALL STANDING WATER.
THAT'S ABOUT SWIMMING POOLS IN
YOUR BACK NOR YARD WITH YOUR
NEIGHBORS COULD ACTUALLY TAKE
YOUR LIFE OR YOUR NEIGHBORS LIKE
THAT HAPPEN TO ME -- A DEAR
FRIEND IN LOS ANGELES LOST HER
LIFE BECAUSE I'D A NEIGHBOR
DIDN'T TAKE CARE THEIR SWIMMING
POOL HAD STANDING WATER
MOSQUITOES -- INFESTED AND THEN
WEST NILE VIRUS BREAKS OUT WHICH
IS A DEVASTATING NEUROLOGICAL
DISORDER.
ACCORDING TO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
PARTS OF LA VENTURA AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTIES RECEIVED.
ALMOST 2100% OF THE AVERAGE
RAINFALL THAT MEANS MORE
MOSQUITO BREEDING SITES AND
STAGNANT WATER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK ISRAEL OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
MORE THAN FORTY THREE HUNDRED
CASES HAVE BEEN REPORTED OF WEST
NILE VIRUS INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN DEATHS. TO RAISE
AWARENESS WE'RE HERE TO DECLARE
APRIL TWENTY FIRST TO TWENTY
SEVEN MISKITO AWARENESS WEEK. TO
SHED LIGHT ON THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT THE MOSQUITOES POSE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WITH ME
TODAY TO STAND IN SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION -- IS IS ONE
OUTSTANDING WORKER IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST MOSQUITO TRANSMITTED
DISEASES -- SOME ERROR OUT
KASHIF -- THE ASSISTANT MANAGER
THE PLASTER MOSQUITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL DISTRICT I KNOW
REPRESENTS SO MANY OTHER THESE
VICTOR DISTRICTS IN YOUR AREAS
PLEASE TO GET THE WORD OUT
AMONGST.
YOUR YOUR NEIGHBORS -- LOVE ONES --
THOSE WITH AREAS THAT RECEIVE
REAL RAINFALL HI THIS IS A REAL
THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK US TO HELP
THESE FOLKS DO THEIR JOB BETTER
SO I THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY -- AND THANK YOU FOR
THE PRIVILEGE OF OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN WELCOME
TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
.
SENATOR SKINNER AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I KNOW IT'S A WE'VE HAD SO MANY
GREAT GUESTS.
SO AS MY GUESTS WALKIN
COLLEAGUES MADAM PRESIDENT.
I ASK THE STATE SENATE CAN JOIN
ME IN GIVING A WARM WELCOME. TO
SOME TERRIFIC YOUNG WOMEN FROM
DISTRICT NINE FOR THEIR
UNPRECEDENTED AND HISTORIC
ACHIEVEMENTS.
THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME TWO
WOMEN HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL
TEAMS FROM THE SAME CITY OAKLAND
ONE STATE CHAMPIONSHIPS ONE IN
DIVISION. THREE ONE IN DIVISION.
FOR SO I AM VERY PROUD TO
INTRODUCE THE YOUNG WOMEN AND
THEIR COACHES FROM OAKLAND HIGH
WHILE GAPS.
IN THE OAKLAND TECH BULLDOGS.
NOW THIS YEAR.
IT IS ALSO THE FIRST TIME THAT
OAKLAND HIGH.
WOMEN'S BASKETBALL TEAM THE
WILDCATS WON THE STATE TITLE.
AND IT'S THE FIRST STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP FOR THE OAKLAND
TECH LADY BULLDOGS SINCE THEY
WON BACK TO BACK STATE TITLES IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE HERE'S MORE
THAT DISTINGUISHES OUR WILD CATS
IN THE LADY.
BULLDOGS BOTH WON THIRTY GAMES
THIS YEAR.
AND THEY BOTH OF SHARED COACH
ORLANDO GRAY WHO'S NOW OAKLAND
HIGHS HEAD COACH BUT HE WAS
FORMERLY THE ASSISTING COACH TO
OAKLAND TAX WINNING TEAMS IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR AND FIVE YEAH.
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN THIS YEAR
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME OUR OAKLAND
HIGH WILDCATS DEFEATED MCFARLAND
HIGH FIFTY ONE TO THIRTY FIVE
WINNING DIVISION.
THREE AND THEY WERE LED BY
SENIOR MORGAN DUNBAR WHO SCORED
EIGHT OR FOR GAME HIGH TWENTY
POINTS IN THE FOURTH QUARTER. TO
STEAL THE WILDCATS VICTORY.
HER FELLOW SENIOR KEIRA MCCOY
SCORED EIGHTEEN POINTS AND MAY
ALEXANDER PULL DOWN THE TEAM'S
BEST NINE REBOUNDS.
WILD CATS ARE ALSO CHAMPS IN THE
CLASSROOM THE TEAM GRADE POINT
AVERAGE IS THREE POINT. SIX
THREE NO THE OAKLAND TECH LADY
BULLDOGS DELIVERY EQUALLY STRONG
PERFORMANCE SWAMPING NOR VIEW OF
YOU KNOW HIGH.
FIFTY FIVE TO TWENTY SEVEN THEY
WERE LED BY JUNIOR POST PLAYER
STEPHANIE YOUR CALL WE OKAY NOW
WE WHO SCORED SIXTEEN POINTS
HAULING IN A DIVISION FOR RECORD
TWENTY FOUR REBOUNDS.
OKAY WE ALSO BLOCK SEVEN AMAZING
SHACKS.
THE LADY BULLDOGS WERE ALSO LED
BY JUNIOR GUARD JORDAN SMITH WHO
POURED IN NINETEEN POINTS.
THE BULLDOGS IN FACT PLAYED
STIFLING CHAMPIONSHIP WINNING
DEFENSE ALL GAME LONG
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
SENATE.
LET'S GIVE YOUNG WOMEN IN
OAKLAND CONGRATULATIONS FOR
THEIR AMAZING PERFORMANCES WERE
ALSO VERY PROUD THAT THE CITY OF
OAKLAND.
THROUGH THEM A PARADE WHICH WAS
EQUALLY AS GOOD AS THE DUBS
PARADE LAST YEAR.
AND IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO HONOR
YOU CANNOT HOLD THEIR JOBS WHEN
THEY WIN THE PLAYOFFS HIS YEAR
HONOR YOU AND HAVE YOU IN THERE.
AGAIN.
DESERVE.
YOUR TRUE CHAMPIONS.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WONDER WOMEN.
ALL RIGHT TRIED FOR PICTURE.
OKAY
RELATIONS LADIES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE LEFT THAT IS FROM
SENATOR ALAN.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I MEMBERS AYE AYE AT BY SERVE
BOTH AS A SENATOR ALAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I AM HONORED
TO SERVE AS THE CO CHAIR THE
SENATE SIDE CHAIR OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL CAUCUS AND OF
COURSE ARE SENATE INVOLVING A
QUALITY COMMITTEE I JUST WANTED.
TO MENTION THAT TODAY IS OF
COURSE EARTH DAY.
APRIL TWENTY SECOND AND A LOT OF
FOLKS MAY NOT KNOW THAT OUR
STATE HAS ITS ORIGINS RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA -- LARGELY IT WAS
SENATORNELSON WHO IS A CENTER
FROM WISCONSIN -- WHO CAME
ACROSS THIS IDEA AFTER
WITNESSING THE RAVAGES OF THE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE MASSIVE OIL
SPILL THAT TOOK PLACE?
IN SENATOR JACKSON'S DISTRICT IN
SANTA BARBARA ND HE WAS
INSPIRED BY SOME OF THE STUDENT
ANTI WAR PROTESTS THAT WERE
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME HE
SAID.
IF WE CAN INFUSE THAT SAME KIND
OF ENERGY WITHIN EMERGING PUBLIC
COSTS PUBLIC CONSCIOUSNESS ABOUT
ABOUT CLEAN AIR AND WATER AND
THEY COULD ACTUALLY FORCE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
ON TO THE NATIONAL POLITICAL
AGENDA AND AND ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND NINETEEN SEVENTY TWENTY
MILLION AMERICANS TOOK TO THE
STREETS UP AND DOWN ALL OVER THE
NATION. TO A TALK ABOUT ABOUT
ABOUT OIL SPILLS POLLUTING
FACTORIES POWER PLANTS RAW
SEWAGE TOXIC DUMPS PESTICIDES
FREEWAYS LOTS OF WILDERNESS.
EXTENSION OF WILDLIFE SUDDENLY --
ALL THESE DIFFERENT GROUPS ON
THE REALIZE THAT THEY HAD COMMON
VALUES IN THE AND THAT THEIR
EXCITING THING IF YOU GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF THE
ORIGINAL EARTH DAY IT REALLY
BROUGHT TOGETHER AN
EXTRAORDINARY.
CROSS SECTION OF AMERICANS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS RICH
AND POOR URBAN FOLKS FARMERS
TYCOONS TYPE LABOR LEADERS -- IT
WAS IT WAS A VERY SPECIAL --
COMING TOGETHER THAT ENDED
LEADING TO THE CREATION OF THE
U. S. ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY THE PASSAGE OF THE CLEAN
AIR CLEAN WATER ENDANGERED
SPECIES AXE A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT MOMENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY -- THAT HELP THAT THAT
IT REALLY DID HELP TO GALVANIZE
OUR OUR MODERN DAY CONSCIOUSNESS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
AND SO I DRIVE I DID NOT WANT
THIS MOMENT TO PASS HERE WE ARE
IN APRIL TWENTY SECOND ON ON THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF EARTH
DAY AND I JUST WANT TO WISH
EVERYBODY A VERY VERY HAPPY --
THING.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN.
SEEING NO FURTHER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WOOD FLOOR AMENDMENTS WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SB.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE.
READING MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL. TWO FIFTY ONE
THREE OF FIVE FOUR EIGHTEEN AND
SENATE BILL.
TWO THIRTY THREE THE SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED READ
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'LL START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATOR PAN.
NOT AT HIS DESK.
FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR GALGIANI.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SENATOR RUBIO.
NOT AT HER DESK FILE ITEM TWELVE
SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY ONE BY
SENATOR DODD ENACT GOING TO
COLLECT BEVERAGES IN THE
CLEANERS THREATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR DODD.
A META PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
TWENTY ONE SIMPLY LOWERS THE
REQUIRED MINIMUM BREWING
PRODUCTION OF A BROUGH PROB
RESTAURANT LICENSE ALSO KNOWN.
AS A AT TYPE SEVENTY FIVE
LICENSE FROM TWO HUNDRED BARRELS
OF BEER PER YEAR TO ONE HUNDRED
BARRELS.
AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT REMEMBER
LAST YEAR SB TWELVE EIGHTY THREE
MADE SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE
BREWPUB.
RESTAURANT LICENSE INCLUDING AN
INCREASE IN THE MINIMUM BERYL
PRODUCTION FROM A HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED BARRELS.
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER SIGNING OF
THE BILL WE HEARD FROM A NUMBER
OF LICENSEES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THAT THE INCREASE BEER
PRODUCTION WOULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THEIR COST IT MIGHT
POTENTIALLY PUT HIM OUT OF
BUSINESS.
SO SB TWENTY ONE CHANGES THE
MINIMUM BREWING PRODUCTION BACK
TO A HUNDRED BARRELS OF BEER.
IT ALSO FIXES A SMALL TECHNICAL
ISSUE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES BY BILL.
I BRIDGES.
HI BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
HI DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OR TOM [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER.
BY STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBER.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SENATOR CHIANG NOT AT HER DESK.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG ENACT REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB ONE FIFTY ONE IS A
VERY SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
SIMPLY ENSURES THAT EVERYONE IS
TREATED EQUALLY IN TERMS OF A
RECALL.
PERMITS ELECTED STATE OFFICIAL
PARTISAN STATE OFFICIAL WHO IS
SUBJECT TO RECALL TO HAVE THEIR
PARTY PREFERENCE.
IDENTIFIED ON THE RECALL BALLOT
UNLIKE -- ELECTED OFFICIALS
[inaudible]
BEING -- RECALL THE RIGHT NOW.
IF A FOR EXAMPLE A REPUBLICAN IS
BEING RECALLED THEY CAN'T HAVE
THEIR PARTY DESIGNATION ON HE
BALLOT SAME THING GOES FOR
DEMOCRATS THIS SIMPLY PERMITS
THAT AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
PERSON BEING RECALLED.
VERSION AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CAMBIADO.
I CHIANG.
I DODD.
HI THE RAZA [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
HI JACKSON.
BY.
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE.
STERN.
HI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI AMBER.
BOB I. CASKEY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER
DODD.
THE PRESIDENT MEMBERS FOOD
INSECURITY IS WIDELY RECOGNIZED
AS A SERIOUS PROBLEM ON UC STATE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES WHERE
THERE'S A GROWING AWARENESS OF
NEGATIVE IMPACT THIS HAS ON
STUDENT SUCCESS.
SB ONE SEVENTY THREE IS INTENDED
TO HELP INCREASE AWARENESS IN
YOU UTILIZATION OF CALIFORNIA'S.
BY A STUDENTS PARTICIPATING WORK
STUDY TO A MORE UNIFORM
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PROCESS.
IN ORDER FOR A COLLEGE STUDENT
ENROLLED AT LEAST HALF TIME TO
APPLY FOR CAL FRESH FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES THAT THEY MEET CERTAIN
EXCEPTIONS ONE BEING CRITERIA --
AS A PARTICIPATION IN WORK STUDY
CURRENTLY MANY COLLEGES YOU
UNIVERSITIES UTILIZE DIFFERENT
FORMS FOR MAKING THE STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION --
PURPOSES MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR COUNTY STAFF TO
PROCESS CAL FRESH APPLICATIONS
TO KNOW CONCLUSIVELY WHEN
STUDENTS MAY QUALIFY FOR AN
ELIGIBILITY EXEMPTION.
SB ONE SEVENTY THREE WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES TO CREATEA STANDARD
FORM THAT STUDENTS CAN TAKE TO
THE COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
STANDARDIZING THIS PROCESS
ACROSS COUNTIES.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT COMMITTEE AND THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THE MEASURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR THANK YOU
CENTER DODD.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO DISCRIMINATION.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES TODAY I'M
PRESIDING SB ONE EIGHT EIGHT THE
CROWN ACT.
TOO THOUGH GOLD ACT TO CREATE A
RESPECTFUL AN OPEN WORKPLACE FOR
NATURAL HAIR.
COLLEAGUES THE PURPOSE OF
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND
BRINGING IT BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
REALLY TWO FOLD.
FIRST TO HELP DISPEL MYTHS AND
EDUCATE THOSE OF YOU WHO NEED IT.
ABOUT THE UNIQUE QUALITIES OF
BLACK HAIR ITS TEXTURE IN THE
BLACK HERE EXPERIENCE.
SECONDLY IF THE CHALLENGE COMMON
HELD MYTHS ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES PROFESSIONALISM IN
THE WORKPLACE.
UNTIL VERY RECENTLY.
A GOOGLE IMAGE SEARCH FOR COLD
UNPROFESSIONAL HERE STYLES
YIELDED ONLY PICTURES OF BLACK
WOMEN WITH THEIR NATURAL HAIR OR
RATE OR WEARING BRAIDS ARE TWO
S..
ALTHOUGH THIS HEARTENING THIS
FACT WAS NOT VERY SURPRISING.
EURO CENTRIC STANDARDS OF BEAUTY
HAVE ESTABLISHED THE VERY
UNDERPINNINGS OF WHAT WAS
ACCEPTABLE AND ATTRACTIVE IN THE
MEDIA.
IN ACADEMIC SETTINGS AND IN THE
WORKPLACE.
AND SO EVEN THOUGH AFTER
AMERICANS WERE NO LONGER
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED FROM THE
WORKPLACE.
BLACK FEATURES AND MANNERISMS
REMAINED UNACCEPTABLE AND QUOTE
ON PROFESSIONAL.
UNTIL RECENT DECADES BLACK MEN
AND WOMEN DIDN'T OFTEN
CHALLENGED THE STANDARDS THEY
DON THEIR WINGS OR STRAIGHTEN
THEIR HAIR WITH HARSH CHEMICAL
RELAXERS. TO MEET THOSE EURO
CENTRIC STANDARDS.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO.
REMINDED ME ABOUT THE CALL.
A A CHEMICAL PROCESS THAT MANY
AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN WAR IN THE
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY.
IT WAS A HAIR STYLE WAS THAT WAS
ARGUE WITH DANGEROUS AND FRANKLY
NOT EVEN PARTICULARLY ATTRACTIVE.
FOR CENTURIES THE BLACK PEOPLE
HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO CONFORM TO
HARSH AND EXPENSE OF STANDARDS
THE CHANGE IN THEIR NATURAL
APPEARANCE.
SOME PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF THE PASS.
THE WERE BEYOND SUCH OUT RIGHT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
APPEARANCE.
AND SOME QUITE FRANKLY AREN'T
QUITE SURE THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
AT ALL.
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW DO PROTECT
FROM DISK INDIVIDUALS FROM
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
RELIGIOUS HAIR STYLES AND HEAD
COVERINGS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL FAR TOO
MANY CASES OF BLACK EMPLOYEES
AND APPLICANTS DENIED EMPLOYMENT
OR PROMOTION.
EVEN TERMINATED BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THEY CHOOSE TO WEAR THEIR
HAIR.
I HAVE HEARD FAR TOO MANY
REPORTS OF BLACK CHILDREN
HUMILIATEDAND SENT HOME FROM
SCHOOL BECAUSE THEIR NATURAL
HAIR WAS DEEMED UNRULY OR A
DISTRACTION TO OTHERS.
CAN WE TRULY SAY THAT EQUITY
EXISTS WHEN OUR CHILDREN ARE
DENIED THE RIGHT TO LEARNING
CLASS BECAUSE OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THEIR HAIR.
WHERE IS THE JUSTICE LA BLACK
MEN AND WOMEN ARE DENIED ACCESS
TO ECONOMIC ADVANCEMENT?
BECAUSE OF THEIR NATURAL
APPEARANCE.
BRAIDS TWISTS AND LOCKS ALSO BE
MOM I PROTECTED RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HAIRSTYLES
LIKE MINE CRIED QUITE FRANKLY
WHICH WOULD WITHOUT QUESTION.
IN AN IMAGE OF PROFESSIONALISM
pWERE NOT INVOLVED.
THE SUPPOSE IT RACE NEUTRAL
WORKPLACE BREWING POLICIES THAT
DAN BRAIDS TWISTS CORN ROWS ARE
LOCKS MAY APPLY TO EMPLOYEES OR
APPLICANTS OF ALL RACES.
HOWEVER THEY HAVE A DISPARATE
IMPACT ON BLACK MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS MEANS THAT THESE POLICIES
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO EXCLUDE
BLACK PEOPLE FROM THE WORKPLACE
THAN PEOPLE OF ANY OTHER RACE.
THERE ARE THOSE WHO IN
OPPOSITION WHO BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL WILL RESULT IN FRIVOLOUS
CLAIMS THAT WILL BURDEN
EMPLOYERS.
OR THAT THE BILL WILL PREVENT
EMPLOYERS FROM REQUIRING THE
WEARING OF HERE NOW SIR OTHER
PROTECTIVE HERE COVERING.
COLLEAGUES THAT IS NOT THE TRUTH.
HOWEVER BY CLEAR FIND IT HERE
TEXTURING HAIRSTYLES ARE TIED TO
RACIAL IDENTITY.
THIS BILL ACTUALLY HELPS MAKE
EMPLOYERS AWARE OF TRAITS THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED.
AND HELP THEM CREATE GROOMING
POLICIES THAT WILL FOSTER
INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY.
SB ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PROTECT
BLACK EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS
FROM BEING FORCED TO CONFORM TO
NON IN CLOSE TO A NON INCLUSIVE
IDEA OF A PROFESSIONAL IMAGE AT
THE EXPENSE.
OF THEIR PERSONAL CHOICE.
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
CLOSE.
CERTAINLY.
I APPRECIATE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD I JUST WANTED TO ADD A
POINT THAT WE AS A BODY
CONSISTENTLY SHOW CAPACITY OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
THE UNDERSTAND THAT EMPATHIZE
WITH THOSE WHO AREN'T LIKE THIS.
WHO COME FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS ETHNICITIES CULTURE
OR RELIGION?
I BELIEVE THAT ANY LAW POLICY OR
PRACTICE THAT SANCTIONS THE JOB
DESCRIPTION THAT IMMEDIATELY
EXCLUDES ME FROM A POSITION.
NOT BECAUSE OF MY CAPACITY OR MY
CAPABILITIES OR MY EXPERIENCE
BUT BECAUSE OF MY HAIR STYLE
CHOICE IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
REFORM.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE OF THIS BE.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
I BILL BY PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG.
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HI HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TADA HI JACKSON.
BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LARK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE BOB I. CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
SENATOR PAN.
NOT AT HIS PASS SOMEBODY THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN FILE ITEM
NINETEEN A CENTER LEYVA PASS ON
FILE FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR
WILK MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY THREE BY
SENATOR BROKE AND ACT GOING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT AND CLEAN THEIR
THREATS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
THAT RISE TO PRESENT SB FIFTY
THREE A MEASURE TO ENSURE
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR STATE BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS.
SB FIFTY THREE CLOSES A LOOPHOLE
IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE BAGLEY
KEENE ACT THAT CURRENTLY ALLOW
SOME STATE ENTITIES THE FORM TO
MEMBER ADVISORY COMMITTEES.
THAT CAN CLOSE OUR DOORS TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE FORMATION OF THESE PRIVATE
COMMITTEES RUN CONTRARY TO THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE BACK
WE CAN ACT.
WHICH WAS TO OPEN UP THE
MEETINGS OF ALL STATE GOVERNMENT
BODIES TO THE PEOPLE FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION.
A SIMILAR FIX TO THE BROWN ACT
WHICH DEFINES OPEN MEETING
REQUIREMENTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WAS MADE IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE TO PREVENT SMALLER
COMMITTEES FOR MEETING WITHOUT
THE OPPORTUNITY OF PUBLIC INPUT.
SB FIFTY THREE WILL SIMPLY PUT
THE OPEN MEETING REQUIREMENTS
FOR STATE GOVERNMENT BODIES IN
LINE WITH WHAT WE DEMAND FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
GREATER TRANSPARENCY LEADS TO
MORE ACCOUNTABLE GOVERNMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR WILK
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NUMBERS TO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BILL. FIVE LARGEST.
HI BRADFORD BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG.
AYE DODD.
I THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES.
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
HI NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
BOB AKOWSKI BY WINNER BY WILK HI.
I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR
BELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BILL AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC CONTRACTS.
SENATE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- SP ONE NINETY
SEVEN WE INTO SUNSET ON THE
CURRENT PROHIBITION.
TRANSFERRING RETENTION PROCEEDS
FROM PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTORS --
RETENTION CAN HAVE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECTS ON CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
BY FORCING CONTRACTORS TO
COMPLETE WORK WITHOUT FULL
PAYMENT AND FORCING THEM TO SELL
FINANCE PROJECTS -- THIS BILL
BRING ALSO BRINGS IT INTO PARITY
FEDERAL RETENTION REQUIREMENTS
BY IMPLEMENTING A UNIFORMED
CONTRACT AND PAYMENT SYSTEMS.
FOR CALTRANS THERE BEEN NO
REPORT ISSUES SAYS SINCE
PROHIBITION WAS FIRST ENACTED.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
CALTRANS ABOVE WITH KNOWLEDGE
THE BILL RESULT IN COST SAVINGS.
I REGION I WROTE ON THIS.
THANK YOU CENTER BELL MEMBERS AS
ARE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USE A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE AYE AYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO CENTER
MCGUIRE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACTUAL INTO
COMMERCIAL FISHING.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IF YOU LOVE
SEA CUCUMBERS THIS IS YOUR BILL.
THE JOINT COMMITTEES ON
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE WORKS
WITH THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE GOLDEN STATE'S COMMERCIAL
AND RECREATIONAL FISHING FLEETS.
AND ADVANCES IN ON THIS BILL
EVERY COUPLE OF YEARS REMEDY
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES BIG AND
SMALL.
SB TWO SIXTY TWO AIMS TO AVOID
LONG TERM FISCAL ISSUES BY
INDEXING INDEXING COMMERCIAL
LANDING FEES OFF OF THE STANDARD
PROGRAM FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF COMMERCE WHICH IS ALREADY IN
PLACE FOR GOODS AND SERVICES.
ACROSS THE NATION.
SECONDLY IT ALSO EXTENDS THE
SUNSET DATE OF THE SEA CUCUMBER
PERMIT PROGRAM THE CURRENT TEN
SAID IS APRIL FIRST. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BY THE WAY THIS YOU
CUCUMBER HALL EVERY YEARS ABOUT
A MILLION DOLLARS IN GROSS
REVENUE THE CASA SOCIALLY WITH
EXTENSION ARE A MINOR IN AMES
DURABLE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER REQUIRE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
[inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT OFF [inaudible]
HI JANE.
DODD.
HI DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE TADO.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
BY STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BY LIKE OWSKI.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
EYES.
THIRTY FOUR MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE.
AYES THIRTY FIVE KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES -- TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE SENATOR PAN.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM TWENTY
FOUR SENATOR SKINNER.
SOME FILE PASS ON FILE BUT LET
HIM TWENTY FIVE SENATOR BILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE BY
SENATOR PELL RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE SENATE BILL.
MATT PRESIDENT MEMBERS SENATE
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT
UNITED STATES TO MOVE AND MOVE
QUICKLY ON INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING A LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IS AGING AND
SERVICE NEEDS OF REPAIR.
WE HAVE WORKED HARD AND GETTING
FUNDING FOR CRUMBLING ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
BUT THIS EFFORT NEEDS TO BE EVEN
BIGGER.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO INCREASE
MOBILITY REDUCE GRIDLOCK AND
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES WE NEED
TO INVEST.
IN OUR PORTS AS KEY DRIVERS OF
OUR ECONOMY TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ARE
VITAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROJECTS PROVIDE GOOD JOBS PORTS
TRUCKS TRUCK ROUTES REAL RATE
RAIL THESE SERVERS ALL SOURCES
OF ON GOING GOOD JOBS.
YES -- SET ROSE JOINT RESOLUTION
FIVE URGES WASHINGTON TO PROVIDE
ALL THE PROMISE INFRASTRUCTURE
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
DELAY THE RESOLUTION URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET TO
WORK.
ON A BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
LEGISLATION.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
ISSUE THAT ALMOST ALL VOTERS
AGREE UPON INVESTING IN PUBLIC
SAFETY IN JOBS AND IN OUR FUTURE.
I IS AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
HI.
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
NO BELL.
HI FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
I THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROVE.
NO.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO BY HER TITLE.
I JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA HIBUY MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
HI.
MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BARBARA CASKEY.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
NO.
I WAS TWENTY SEVEN NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHIANG.
NO MITCHELL ARE.
EYES TWENTY EIGHT THOSE TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE AND I'M TWENTY SIX SENATOR
GLAZER.
PASS ON FILE FILE AND TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR SKINNER.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
OKAY SENATE BILL FOR NINETEEN BY
SENATOR SINNER AND ACTUALLY NEW
PEOPLE DISCIPLINE.
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MEMBERS AND
MADAM PRESIDENT.
SB.
FOUR NINETEEN PURPOSE IS TO HELP
OUR KIDS STAY IN SCHOOL AND TO
GRADUATE.
THE STATISTICS SHOW THAT IF YOU
ARE SUSPENDED FROM SCHOOL YOUR
LIKELIHOOD OF DROPPING OUT IN
YOUR LIKELIHOOD OF NOT
GRADUATING GOES UP [inaudible]
VERY HIGH.
WHAT SB FOUR NINETEEN DOES IS
ELIMINATES ONE CATEGORY A SINGLE
CATEGORY OF SUSPENSIONS WHICH IS
CALLED WILLFUL DEFIANCE?
AND WILL FOR THE FINANCE IS ONE
OF THOSE CATEGORIES THAT'S
PRETTY SUBJECTIVE.
NOW BEFORE I GO FURTHER.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
EVERY OTHER CATEGORY OF
SUSPENSION AND I'M HOLDING THE
AD CODE.
HERE IN MY HANDS EVERY OTHER
CATEGORY OF WHICH THERE ARE MANY
MANY MANY INCLUDING CAUSING
PHYSICAL INJURY VIOLENCE WEAPONS
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES BULLYING
DAMAGING SCHOOL PROPERTY.
OBSCENITY SEXUAL ASSAULT ANY
OTHER NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS I
DIDN'T READ THEM ALL
[inaudible]
REMAIN GROUNDS FOR SUSPENSION.
THIS BILL ONLY ELIMINATES THIS
SUBJECTIVE CATEGORY CALLED
WILLFUL DEFIANCE.
NOW THE DATA SHOWS THAT.
BLACK BROWN DISABLED AND LGBTQ
KIDS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY WILLFUL DEFINED
SUSPENSIONS.
SB FORD.
NINETEEN RESERVES THE RIGHT FOR
A TEACHER TO REMOVE THE STUDENT
WHO MIGHT BE DESTRUCTIVE FROM A
CLASSROOM.
IT JUST DOESN'T ALLOW FOR A
SUSPENSION FROM SCHOOL.
CURRENTLY IN STATUTE.
OUR GRADES KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
THIRD DO NOT HAVE THIS CATEGORY
OF OF A SUSPENSIONS -- BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS PROTECT
CHILDREN FROM GRADES FOUR TO
TWELVE BUT IT PUTS US SUNSET ON
THE HIGH SCHOOL YOU.
YEARS NINETY TWELVE A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET SO WE CAN WAY WHETHER
THERE'S BEEN ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THE ELIMINATION
OF THIS FOR HIGH SCHOOL.
THE BILL PASSED SENATE ED SIX
ZERO WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
I POOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHANGE [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
BY STERN HI BY STONE.
NO NUMBER.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO. FIVE THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON UP FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE SENATOR HUESO.
PASS SOME FILE.
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING
TO THE CONSENT AND SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FROM EITHER OF THOSE
CALENDARS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ALL ITEMS
ON BOTH CALENDARS.
SENATE BILL 680-612-9280 THREE
THREE NINETY THREE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIX SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY SIX ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. TO EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT AND SOME A
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
APPROVED.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A
JOURNEY IN MEMORIES [inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
MEMBER TODAY I RISE TO JOIN IN
THE MEMORY OF DR JULIA REED HAIR
DOCTOR HERE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE IN TULSA OKLAHOMA
AND SHE LIVED AND WORKED.
IN THE GREAT CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO FOR MOST OF MOST OF
HER LIFE UNTIL HER PASSING THIS
PAST FEBRUARY.
HER STORY IS ONE OF LOVE AND
INSPIRATION SHE WAS A LIFELONG
LEARNER PHENOMENAL TEACHER
DYNAMIC SPEAKER AND FEAR FACTOR
THIS.
DOCTOR HERE TOGETHER WITH HER
HUSBAND OF SIXTY YEARS DOCTOR
NATHAN HERE WHO IS OFTEN CALLED
THE FATHER OF BLACK STUDIES
FOUND IN WHAT'S CALLED THE BLACK
THINK TANK.
AND SERVED AS ITS NATIONAL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
AT THE BLACK THINK TANK THE
HERE'S WERE COMMITTED TO
HIGHLIGHTING CELEBRATED IN
EDUCATING ON THE HISTORY CULTURE
EDUCATIONAL STUDIES AND POLITICS
OF BLACK AMERICANS.
TOGETHER WHICH IS HOW THEY DID
EVERYTHING THEY ALSO WROTE AND
PUBLISHED NUMEROUS BOOKS ON
BLACK FAMILIES IN HISTORY SOME
OF WHICH INCLUDED THE IN DANGER
BLACK FAMILY.
THE MIS EDUCATION OF THE BLACK
CHILD.
AND MANY OTHERS AS A SOCIOLOGIST
PSYCHOLOGIST DOCTOR HERE WITH
COMMITTED TO THE GROWTH AND
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT OF BLACK
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THIS IS WHY FOR MANY REASONS IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT EBONY
MAGAZINE RECOGNIZED HER AS ONE
OF THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MOST INFLUENTIAL AFRICAN
AMERICANS IN THE COUNTRY.
A GREAT GIVES ME GREAT HONOR TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF SOMEONE
SO POWERFUL AND DIPLOMATIC AND
WHO TOUCHED THE LIVES OF MANY.
BY HER MERE PRESENCE DR JULIA
HARE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
I COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE -- TO ADDS
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF GINO LUNA A PROMINENT
COMMUNITY MEMBER IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND A LONG TIME CLIENTS OF THE
ARK SAN FRANCISCO.
A CLIENT OF THE ARC SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT GINA WAS A
WELL KNOWN -- PRESENCE AMONG
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS STAFF AND
THE WIDER COMMUNITY -- I CAN'T
EVEN BEGIN TO COUNT THE NUMBER
OF COMMUNITY EVENTS OVER THE
YEARS THAT I'VE ATTENDED --
WHERE SHE WAS THERE -- VERY
POSITIVE ENERGY I JUST A VERY
VERY LOVELY -- HUMAN BEING HI
GINA LIVED INDEPENDENTLY IN HER
OWN STUDIO AT THE ARC MERCY
APARTMENTS -- WHICH WAS A LONG
AWAITED DREAM -- THE CAME TRUE
ONLY RECENTLY.
A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES -- GINO WAS OF A
VOCAL MEMBER OF THE CLIENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND MADE
HERSELF KNOWN TO BOTH LOCAL AND
STATE POLITICIANS MYSELF
INCLUDED.
AT RALLIES AND EVENTS
CHAMPIONING THE RIGHTS OF HER
PEERS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
SHE BROUGHT PASSION AND
EXUBERANCE TO OUR FRIENDSHIPS
HER ADVOCACY AND HER LIFE.
BUDGET WILL BE GREATLY MISSED BY
ALL OF THE PEOPLE SHE KNEW AND
TIDES OF THE ARK AND THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY -- I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN THE SENATE TODAY IN
MEMORY OF JEAN OTHER ENOUGH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED THIRD OF BURKE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO ASK THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF MY DEAR
FRIEND FRANK BARBERO -- FRANK
BARBERO.
WAS A MAN OF MANY PASSIONS HE
WAS PASSIONATE.
IN A WARRIOR FOR THE COMMON MAN
IN COMMON WOMAN THROUGH HIS.
ADVOCACY HIS TRIAL SKILLS.
HIS PASSION ABOUT POLITICS HE
WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT HIS FAMILY.
WHOSE PASSION ABOUT HIS ALMA
MATER USC.
IN A FLAW IT WAS THAT.
FRANK WAS A PERSON WHO DEDICATED
HIS LIFE.
THE ORANGE COUNTY.
HE WAS THE CHAIR OF THE JIMMY
CARTER FOR PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN
JERRY BROWN FOR GOVERNOR CENTER
BILL BRADLEY'S LOCAL CAMPAIGN
EDWARD KENNEDY ALAN CRANSTON.
JOHN KERRY ROCK OBAMA HILLARY
CLINTON YOU MAY NOTICE A THEME
THERE.
FRANK WAS A PERSON.
WHO WAS UNIVERSALLY ADMIRED?
AND HIS LEGACY.
AS IS A LEGACY FOR ALL OF US IS
NOT JUST OUR WORK [inaudible]
BUT WHAT PEOPLE REMEMBER US FOR
AND THE FACT THAT WE WILL
REMEMBER FRANK FOR THOSE
PASSIONS.
IN PARTICULAR. FOR THE PASSIONS
HE INSTILLED IN HIS CHILDREN.
BRED IN KC.
WHO ARE BOTH STILL CONTRIBUTING
CONTRIBUTING TODAY?
TO MEDICINE CONTRIBUTING TODAY
TO MEDICAL RESEARCH.
HE LEAVES BEHIND DAUGHTERS IN
LAW.
DOROTHY IN SHANNON.
AND GRAND CHILDREN BROCK AND
EMERSON AND SISTER LAURA.
IN A GRAND CHILD TO BE BORN HERE
THIS SUMMER -- FRANK WAS A
STELLAR HUMAN BEING.
AND AN EXAMPLE FOR ALL OF US
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU CENTER AMBERG PLEASE BE SURE
TO BRING HIS NAME FORCE WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
MEMBERS THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR ANY
ANNOUNCEMENTS ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR HANNAH
BETH JACKSON.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS DENIM DAY HAS BEEN
CELEBRATED ON A WEDNESDAY.
IN APRIL.
IN ORDER SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AWARENESS MONTH.
THIS WEDNESDAY WE WILL BE
CONTINUING THAT TRADITION.
THE TRADITION THE CAMPAIGN WAS
TRIGGERED BY A RULING THAT
ACTUALLY OCCURRED.
IN THE ITALIAN SUPREME COURT
WHICH OVERTURNED A RAPE
CONVICTION BECAUSE THE JUSTICES
FELT THAT SINCE THE VICTIM.
WAS WEARING TIGHT JEANS SHE MUST
HAVE HELPED HER RAPIST REMOVE
THEM.
THEREBY IMPLYING CONSENT.
I KID YOU NOT.
THIS WAS THEIR RULING.
THE FOLLOWING DAY HOWEVER THE
WOMEN IN THE ITALIAN PARLIAMENT
CAME TO WORK WEARING JEANS.
IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE VICTIMS.
SINCE THEN WEARING JEANS ¡N
DENIM DAYS BECOME A SYMBOL OF
PROTEST AGAINST THE RONI IS AND
DESTRUCTIVE ATTITUDES THAT EXIST
ABOUT SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THIS YEAR'S DENHAM DAYS JUST
WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY FOURTH.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ELECTED
OFFICIALS LIKE OURSELVES
BUSINESS AND STUDENTS.
MAKE A SOCIAL STATEMENT THOSE
THOSE ARE STAFF I KNOW THEY COME
IN.
THE LIGHTED TO BE ABLE TO WEAR
JEANS DURING THE WEEK.
BUT IT IS A SYMBOLIC OF A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUE.
AND BY WEARING THESE JEANS ON
THIS DAY IT CREATES A VISIBLE
MEANS OF PROTEST AGAINST THE
MISCONCEPTIONS.
THAT SURROUND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL ENSURE THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
AND JOIN WITH ME IN A KNOWLEDGE
IN DENIM DAY.
AND SHOWING YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
BY WEARING JEANS IN HONOR OF
THIS VICTIM OF THE ITALIAN
SUPREME COURT AND HER RAPIST
MANY YEARS AGO.
UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL HAVE A
GREAT.
DEAL OF WORK TO DO TO IN THIS
SCOURGE OF VIOLENCE AND ASK YOU
IN TO JOIN IN THAT SYMBOLIC
GESTURE ON WEDNESDAY.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON CENTER
HER TADO.
THE FOR PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING AT OFF
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER PLAN
ADJOURNMENT OF FOR SESSION TODAY
THANK YOU CENTER HER TADO CENTER
GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENT TO
SELECT MEMBERS KNOW THAT THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE DIDN'T COMPLETE ITS
WORK THIS MORNING SO WILL
CONTINUE AT THE ADJOURNMENT OF
OUR SESSION TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ANYTHING FURTHER.
THIRD A WINNER SO SORRY PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I THE I HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE ON A GERMAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
MADAM PRO TEM THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
IT'S LOUD.
I WANT TO WELCOME MY COLLEAGUES
BACK HOPEFULLY FROM A RESTFUL
AND PRODUCTIVE SPRING BREAK WE
WILL RECONVENE HERE THURSDAY
MORNING AT NINE AM SHARP THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE WENT MADE WE WILL
WORK WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE
DAY